great whites are the most feared
predator in the ocean they typically
hunt large mammals like seals sea lions
and whales but they are also responsible
for more attacks on humans than any
other shark species and that's not all
when Collier digs into the details from
the other four incidents in 2014 it
appears they were all carried out by
white sharks so what's making the great
whites of southern california suddenly
go on the attack
Thanks
according to shark expert dr. Andrew
nosal a great whites actions are highly
driven by the presence of prey and a
major food source for these predators
can be found along the coast here in
abundance there's a seal pinnipeds a
great whites favorite food are pinnipeds
like the California sea lions we see
behind us and they like them because
they're full of fat and full of
nutrients
but there may be a particular time when
sharks need to gorge themselves on these
pinnipeds right before they make an
incredible annual journey to a remote
and mysterious location nicknamed the
white shark cafe the white shark cafe is
located about halfway between California
and Hawaii so right about here in the
middle of the open ocean dubbed a pool
of nothing
this unremarkable patch of sea is
roughly the size of Colorado and for
some reason every year great whites that
typically swim solo gather here by the
hundreds as part of the largest known
congregation of white sharks in the
world it's unclear what the purpose of
the white shark cafe is but one theory
is that this is a place where mating is
actually happening not only that but
these predators remain here in the
middle of nowhere for months we
typically see the white sharks leaving
California about November December and
then late summer is when we see them
start showing up again off the coast of
California but this long-term stay seems
odd because there appears to be a
distinct lack of one crucial thing at
the Kafe food
for a long time we thought that it was a
desert of sorts there was nothing there
so if there's nothing to eat when they
arrive could great whites be stocking up
on pinnipeds before the journey in order
to sustain themselves white sharks want
the easy meal so they're gonna go to a
place where there's a lot of seals and
sea lions a place like the California
coast
so our humans here simply in the middle
of a feeding frenzy is that what's
causing this alarming spike in attacks
according to Nosal the answer lies far
below the surface of the cafe where in
2018 scientists make an unexpected
finding involving the very thing that
appeared to be absent food turns out
that there's actually a lot living there
there's all kinds of fish and crabs and
things in the water there
this prey just lives much deeper than
could previously be seen on satellite
images so because they're feeding there
I don't think the white shark stocking
up on food right before their migration
is a sound explanation for the uptick in
shark bites something else must be
driving great whites to attack and maybe
it isn't what they're hunting but what's
under them
[Music]